i told you i had this out of body
experience last night i was looking at
some of the videos that we've got on the
channel which is these vlogs
and i i i was not associating with
myself in that moment i was just looking
at it through the eyes of like a neutral
person yeah and i saw a guy
who was in america yeah interviewing sam
harris bill burr he's doing joe rogan
[Music]
and he was only like 10 minutes later
that i realized that guy was me yeah
[Music]
and i was like [ __ ]
that's incredible yeah
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry
destroys america i'm francis foster i'm
constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with fascinating people we don't have
either of those for you today because
today it's just us reviewing the trip
we've just finished francis bilber
walked out of the door behind you two
hours ago
and he says we're best friends so
did he say that just i i wasn't there
for that part no well no he didn't but i
know he meant it i know he meant yeah
you know he meant it but no it was what
an incredible interview well the
interview itself was incredible but i
want to talk about the whole trip okay
because working our way back today was
bill burr yesterday was adam carolla and
sam harris before that we were in
nashville where we interviewed matt
walsh colin wright colin wright as well
before that we were in austin texas
where i mean we went on joe rogan's show
which was incredible
uh we we were very diplomatic yeah i
fell yeah we were i mean i was i'm just
like
what do you mean so were you i was
diplomatic
literally just said most british
comedians suck and you go forth and then
said yeah i agree with you
knowing we're about to go to edinburgh
where we're going to be surrounded by
the very people who all got triggered by
that comment yeah but did they they're
all blaming me
yeah but
we've blamed your people since time and
yeah i know i know blaming the jews is
the customary way of doing it yeah i
just didn't expect it coming from you
but it's just because just because you
look jewish as well yeah no it works so
beautifully do you know what i mean your
people have been excelling at that for
generations who am i to stop this
wonderful tradition
unbelievable
anyway so big joey we we went on joe's
show
that was absolutely mind-blowing and the
one thing i take away most of all from
this trip actually is
i learned this from our experience on on
being on joe show and i said it to him
and it because it was true afterwards
like i always thought of going and
spending four hours or however long it
would be with joe as an opportunity
i did not realize how much fun it would
be yeah it was incredible fun it would
but and by the end of it what was insane
for me is like here we are and i and i
was just in this mode that you and i
would be if we're sitting in a
restaurant or at the studio or whatever
um where it's like we talk about sport
and boxing and we're just shooting the
[ __ ] about the ufc and i was like oh
yeah i've got this point to send and
then i and then i was like wait wait
this is the guy that's interviewed like
every ufc champion ever and actually
knows what he's talking about yeah
you know what's very interesting as well
is
how much of a difference did that blunt
make
to the entire interview into the entire
change the interview it changed the
direction it was perfectly timed yeah it
was it was because you know for two
hours if we were talking about culture
war we were talking about very serious
issues like the grooming gangs yeah and
we were talking about political
correctness free speech
and then we did a good solid chunk of
that classic trig
yeah
then the old bifters came out and we
went
in a different direction but we've never
talked about like spirituality on the
show in that way
um i tell you what what the you you
talked about with br when we when we did
the podcast bridge of fantasy how for
you there was a moment where it was oh
[ __ ] this is joe rogan yeah right when
he walked in i didn't feel that but what
i did feel is the moment he asked me
about whether putin is going to use a
nuke yeah and i was already stoned yeah
i was like
i better wake up like i better pay
attention here because yeah i mean
didn't [ __ ] about you did he just soften
you up give your blood and then just bam
and justin because he wanted the real
one yeah he wanted this one
yeah but no it was it was incredible
experience and then the next day see the
thing is with doing rogan is it's a
journey and it sounds really wanky but
it kind of is because you've been
preparing for it for so long yeah and
even when you you're not preparing from
it for it you're still kind of on that
path anyway because you've got to start
your thing you've got to do it you've
got to practice it you've got to become
really good at it
you then do the podcast
and then you leave the room
and then the next day you just prepare
for the fall up
and i think probably all his guests get
that to a certain degree
everybody goes through i mean not all
his guests come on there and [ __ ] on
their former industry for an hour
straight mate
only me and you have that level of troll
yeah exactly exactly
but it what a magical experience it was
yeah man what a guy what a guy
and then remember when we went to the
comedy night afterwards yeah that was
incredible that was completely
mind-blowing because he was just so
uncensored yeah i haven't seen anything
like that in my life no it was
it was brilliant a lot not a lot but
some of the jokes were too fine for me
but i was like
at least someone's able to make them
yeah exactly just because i don't
personally like them doesn't mean i want
people not to be able to make them yeah
um and in the uk that would literally
never happen and then you wrote a tweet
about that and then that went really
that went down really well
yeah so uh what an experience but joe is
such a legitimate dude like
one thing that he did is he helped us
with a lot of the other things that we
were doing and i don't want to you know
talk about it publicly but he's a
legitimate guy and i know this from
other people again not can't say how but
we
like he's someone who really likes
helping other people he wants to help
you be better this is what we talked
about on the show like
i think we forget
how different the british comedy scene
and culture is
on the in this respect yeah exactly like
everyone is pulling everyone down no one
wants anyone to do well and here is just
the opposite and it's also partially and
i know you're gonna say i've got a chip
on my shoulder it's partially a class
thing for [ __ ] sake it's true oh no i
grew up without money man
you know people don't want you to get to
that next level
they just don't want it what is your
worth because you've got the wrong
accent exactly where you are yes
see this is the thing with you mate you
you want to ram your class in every
[ __ ] orifice of every conversation
yes i do
what is that
because
i genuinely think it's not something
that we don't go anywhere near as much
to addressing it as we should
we just don't i think it's true you know
and our this is what i love about
america our society and i love britain
i've been having people saying yeah i do
love it it's my home
but everything is stratified everybody
knows their strata where they are etc
you come to america it's like somebody
just got the cards and thrown them up in
the air i know what you mean but so much
of that is just in your head man
it is
look at you look what you're seeing
in america
yeah
you've made it yeah
but we did it
on our own yeah we didn't go through the
tradition but no one's holding us down
yeah no one's got oh france has got a
weird accent no except me yeah that is
true
get them out here yeah but at the bbc
yeah
well you're not nonce enough for the
beast yeah that is true that is true
you're not that interested in kids
exactly and i was proving innocent of
all charges so tick tick exactly
and that has been the the wonderful
thing about america the thing that i
have loved
there's an energy here there's a
positivity yeah when you come here you
can feel yourself tap into it yeah and
no one's looking at you going where is
this person coming from in society yeah
people just they they you know they want
to do well and they want other people to
do well now look in every country
there's going to be good people and bad
people and stupid people and clever
people and all sorts of it
uh and i know that in so in the us
there's a lot of sort of like bitching
and fighting against you know among
comedians of different scenes etc but
it does feel like a completely different
experience and one of the things for us
is we've really expanded our friendship
circle while we've been here like most
of the people we've met
you know we haven't even talked about
the time we spent in virginia before
austin where
we stayed with seb gorka who's a big fan
of the show and a friend of ours
and it took us to shoot some guns too
some guns experience some freedom all
this stuff was like enough vlogs that
our supporters see and that's another
thing that's been incredible like i i
told you i had this out of body
experience last night uh now admittedly
we had
had
a bit more of the weed yeah but
the reason i bring it up is like i was
looking at my phone
and checking our stats which i don't
usually do you know we don't look at
that really ever
no we don't definitely don't look at it
every night no or every morning yeah we
definitely don't do that but i was
looking at at our stats and i was
looking at uh some of the videos that
we've got on the channel which is these
vlogs
and i i i was not associating with
myself in that moment i was just looking
at it through the eyes of like a neutral
person yeah and i saw a guy
who is in america
interviewing sam harris bill burr is
doing joe rogan
and he was only like 10 minutes later
that i realized that guy was me yeah
and we're like traveling around
documenting the trip checking
interesting things out making friends
and i was like [ __ ]
that's incredible yeah yeah the fact
that we are able to do this the fact
that
we've got so many people who are
watching us listening to us willing us
on giving us money joining locals doing
all of these different things even or
even just listening or watching it's
still amazing that people are willing to
give their time to listen to idiot
comedians that to me blows me and i
guess it blows me away every single time
and what i want the more we grow is to
have more experiences like this i want
to take on our audiences on our audience
on even more of a journey
because i think the magic of this trip
was and people messaged me they were
like i've been watching you since 2019
or 2018 and seeing you go on rogue and
makes me so proud you know like it's
like a band like you see him in the back
of a pub and then you watch and grow and
do bigger stuff and whatever else yeah
and i just really looking forward to
when we do even more incredible things
just bring everyone on a journey with us
yeah man the vlogs of i think are going
to be potentially a very interesting
part of the future of the show yeah
because people want to see like that how
it actually happens you know um and i
that that's fascinating to me looking
into that so we'll see what we can do
but uh elliot who's our in uh intern uh
you know will be getting a nice
bonus yeah because of the work he's done
and making those vlogs 50 quid coming
each week he's going to say 20 but you
know you know what i mean
yeah so
that's been absolutely mind-blowing and
the number of people who like us here
who watch us here we had someone come up
to us in la who works for like a massive
movie star we had people we had people
come up to us in every city that we've
been in absolutely think about that
think think how incredible that is yeah
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
bridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anton has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
and what's really exciting and what you
know what i love about
when we get a big name guest on
they always come in they're always like
a little bit you know like a cat when
it's going into a new place it's a
little bit like yes
and it's just like what's going on they
sit down and they're like
they have a bit of a chat they got us
all right
and then they get into it yeah and
they're still
but a lot of the time either you or i
manages to find that way in and then it
goes
yeah
yeah yeah it was like that with bill
today yeah
he was like that with joe you did it
with joe yeah there was a moment uh you
were very wise to mention the weed yeah
yeah exactly you whipped the blunt right
out yeah exactly and jun and then you
walk away like with one of our guests
and i won't say who it is
they came in with a fist bump and
they're left with a handshake yeah
you know yeah
i love that
you've just managed to open something up
in people and then people get to
understand who they truly are yeah and
why they think the way they think yeah
that was fascinating it's amazing yeah
it's brilliant i i love that today uh
and every every other day that we've
done and there's been some uh challenges
like when we first arrived all our
equipment didn't show up basically we
had nothing so we had to run around new
york
um
so we you know there were some
challenges but it's been an absolute joy
an absolute joy
if this trip
it's felt slightly magical yeah
this this seems to have that kind of
magical quality about it yeah
and it's just it's difficult to describe
well i think we came to a place that we
we haven't really been in in this way
like it's different being here doing
what we were doing yeah we're meeting
people we're literally in the place
where like the industry that we're in
yeah is being created and cancelled and
cancelled every day yeah right but if
you're into podcasting
or if you're into standard yeah
or if you're into politics or into
philosophy we have met and interviewed
on this trip
people who are literally at the pinnacle
of that yeah
bill burr is at the pinnacle of stand up
yeah joe rogan is the pinnacle of
podcasting
right
yeah sam harris is the pinnacle of the
political and philosophy conversation
now you know he's got once you get to
those points people become controversial
and some people will disagree with them
but there's no question that sam harris
is one of the world's most prominent
public intellectuals in the last five
years five seven years that's just what
he is yeah he's him jordan peterson
douglas murray you know
these are public intellectuals at that
level
um
so on all those fronts we've been
literally talking to the people who are
making and shaping that world yeah
and it's been fascinating
this trip has felt
like this trip has felt far longer than
two and a half weeks yeah and i was
thinking to myself why is that and it's
because we're having such incredible
experiences
that time is slowing down yeah there was
a point in the rogue an interview
well i lost track of all time that would
be the weed mate yeah that will be the
weed
but it's also you know i've had it so
often since we've been here like days
last forever
because we're experiencing so much we're
meeting so many incredible people we're
growing as a result
like we're going to come back all three
of us
different than when we went yeah there's
no question about it i think we're
already different one of the ways i'm
different you know i am really really
keen that trigonometry becomes a vehicle
now in the uk
for people who are doing good things
to get a bigger audience yeah i think in
the past
i was so focused on growing what we are
growing that it didn't occur to me that
we are actually now in a position to
help other people yeah you know and if
someone is doing good work
why can't we do what joe does here which
is you know there are people who have i
don't know 30 000
subscribers on youtube
and
in the past we were so focused on
growing our audience that we wanted to
talk to them but it was it was difficult
to reconcile with with the fact that we
want more people to watch the show right
so you have to get people with a bigger
audience and we always tried like we
always gave people an opportunity
you know when it when we felt that it
was really
worth it you know and obviously like
when you're talking about serious issues
you get someone on no matter how big an
audience they have like dr hill is a
good example like that is the interview
i am most proud of that we have done and
i include this trip yeah right and that
interview was never gonna get more than
like a hundred thousand views or
whatever it's on
but for the most part you have to focus
on getting people who are big names yeah
you know and part of the conversation at
that level and
now i feel you know we have a
responsibility to take on
joe's attitude which is building a
community of people that's what i
learned from him
and support people who are coming up you
know
and there's so many people that in the
uk are doing good stuff
and we don't even know a lot of them yet
because again we've been so focused on
what we've been doing but there are lots
of people comedians and and other people
who who are trying to make stuff yeah
why not bring them along why not why not
give them an opportunity and i think
that's really important because like you
said that was the inspiring thing about
joe that he said
he gets on people who have nowhere near
the size of an audience yeah that
wouldn't
that you know you would want to bring on
to so that people would hear about the
podcast that people would understand it
but he believes that they have something
of value to add
and that he can help them along the way
yeah
and look he's been burned we've been
burned yeah but it's really important
that you bring people in you give them a
chance so that they can then go on
and create amazing things yeah well and
look uh you know whatever people think
about the two people i'm going to
mention the fact is they're important
figures in the culture in the cultural
space
we were the first people as far as i
know to do a long-form interview with
zubi
yep and we were the first people as far
as i know to do a long-form interview
with lawrence fox yeah right
um
i i i mean i'm not saying we made them
we did but yeah i'm not saying that you
should be grateful
no i'm obviously not saying it but you
know what i mean there are lots of
people out there who have got you know
opinions that they're strongly held and
they're people of charisma and character
and whatever you know and we may
agree with everything that person does
down the line or not but
you know i think it's really important
for us to to encourage people who want
to speak their mind yeah whatever
position they're coming from actually
you know like a lot of comedians had a
go at us for what we said on rogan but
i'd if there are people who
have something interesting to say and
who are building something cool and
exciting that don't agree with us i'd
love to have them on let's talk yeah you
know
i don't i i'm not like i'm not this this
experience of
being here
is so been so powerfully positively
inspiring yeah though i don't have any
of that like oh we're gonna we're gonna
shut you out just because you have the
wrong opinion i really don't you know
and it's very tempting and i think it's
important that
we
we do that i also think it's important
like if we see like a comedian who's
been like a dick to us but maybe they're
going through their own stuff and people
are going to try and cancel them for
innocuous you know we just quote tweet
it in with the words ha ha exactly no
but we don't [ __ ] yeah how does that
taste
no
it's actually really important that we
actually reach out and go
hey hey brother you okay yeah
just here if you need just let me know
yeah because
it's important for people to understand
that
we put we platform
when we try to platform
everybody
with regards to the exceptions at either
end but everybody else you've got a
chance of coming on here if you've got
something valuable to say yeah but also
you know if you're going through your
own stuff if you know if you if you're
in danger if you've you know you've got
people who are coming for you and trying
to take away your career and everything
that you can come to us and we will give
you a fair hearing
and you'll be able to per se
and put across your experiences yeah and
that's really important yeah i agree
so this experience has just been
it's been the deep programming from a
lot of kind of cultural indoctrination
that we have in the uk that i've needed
um
as for you know a lot of people were
asking like are we moving to texas or
whatever like uh i don't think we will
be right away but i definitely think
we'll be spending more time in america
than we have been
well we haven't been spending any time
in america so this is yeah but like
we'll be back and probably quite soon
and probably
for a period of time yeah
but we'll see we'll see how that goes
we'll see how that goes but i also feel
you know like i
i mean you can't
pretend that when joe rogan says to you
live in front of millions of people
and also then like in private
you should come i really want you to
come and be part of the community here
like you can't deny that that's
flattering and very appealing
particularly because austin is [ __ ]
incredible yeah
and it's also as well you've got you
need to try it yeah you need to try it
but where i was going was also
i do feel
the
you know we are a british
show yeah and the people who watched us
from the beginning and the people who
supported us from the beginning and the
people who
who were really invested in our show
yeah a lot of them are from britain
and the issues we talk about are
important to them
in their lives
and to just like abandon them and just
jump on the bandwagon of
the united states i don't think that
would be the right move for us that's
not to say that we may not eventually
just
for whatever reason feel like this is
the place that we've got to be for you
know for longer or permanently but at
the moment i feel like you know there's
such important battles being for and
actually there are some wins going on
you know gender ideology in the time
that we've been away tavistock has been
shut down we had a whistleblower from
tavistock come and talk about it yeah to
hundreds of thousands of people
yeah government ministers i bet you who
who made that decision
and who who were part of the process of
that whole thing they would have watched
that interview yeah absolutely that
that's just one example and there's been
others too
and
that's the thing about the uk is it's
still our home we still consider
ourselves british
and there's so many problems here at the
moment there's so many things that we
need to talk about there's so many
things that aren't being talked about in
nearly as honest a way as they should be
and we really need to go back and talk
to these people and expose
what is happening and all these
different you know in in all these
different facets of society
it needs to be done because
we were the ones doing it no there were
other people who've come along but i
like to think that we do it best
and that we need to be back yeah
i agree and also
uh you know our raw shows yeah not
everybody's cup of tea for sure yep
because some people are frigid yeah
exactly minges and not in a good way
too far but anyway
uh what i was going to say is
we met one of our top supporters
here in new york nathan woodard and one
of the things she said to us
i never really thought about it like
that because it's a kind of you know if
you think that about yourself it's an
arrogant way of looking at it but on raw
we combine
offensive but funny comedy
with
what i'd like to think is a fair-minded
political analysis yeah
that will take the piss out of the
people on the left and the right when
they go wrong now look we have our
views of things and at the moment the
far left concerns us more yeah because
it's more numerous and it's captured
institutions and so on whatever but we
are combining a fair-minded political
commentary with humor and what nathan
said to us he said you're not the best
at what you do you're the only people
who do that
and i'm not i'm certainly not aware of
any comparable show and i don't think
you could do a comparable show on tv
even on even on somewhere you know like
gb news where the guys do a good job you
know but it's still constrained by the
parameters of television
uh boys what we do is
raw
exactly and
raw works because we're british because
we take a british
attitude
and a british way of looking at the
world a british lens and just cast it
across the globe
and the people who watch us tend to be
you know people from all over the world
but they tend to be two things they tend
to be anglophiles number one and number
two they're lovers of british comedy
so they watch this and they get this
sort of rye look at the world very
cynical
and that's british and i love american
humor and i love americans are you gonna
[ __ ] on american stand-ups no you're
gonna do both in
one trip no no i love british humor and
the american comics all suck yeah they
all suck no
but that way of looking at the world of
going
this is [ __ ] isn't it
that's british yeah
yeah that's what we do best yeah that's
what we and that's what that's what raw
is
yeah he's looking at all these different
complex complex
difficult you know subjects and events
and just going
it's a bit [ __ ] in it yeah
and combined with
you know
we push every boundary yeah you know
comedically yeah it's fun yeah it's a
lot of fun man so i look forward to
getting back in and getting the raw
started back up yeah uh and of course
i mean we've recorded like incredible
interviews that i look forward to
putting out for like you'll last us a
month
i'm so excited for people to see these
interviews i mean sam harris you know
that's gonna piss off a hell of a lot of
people but also there's a bit in there
when he talks about how to live a happy
life that's just brilliant you know uh
bill burr
for hilarious yeah adam carolla talking
about you know how california has become
like a super progressive and therefore
very restricted place yeah and being
really funny and talking about you know
the working class situation and all of
that matt walsh was brilliant matt walsh
was very good and i challenged him
pretty hard on the feminist stuff you
know yeah so people
people will i think feel like it was a
you know he got asked the right
questions yep at least from me i think
there's something we probably left out
that posey might might she might revoke
the praise that she had for us after
rogan but we'll see
um you know janja kellig very
interesting yeah
coleman hughes always great mark norman
tyler fisher is a great interview you
know uh theo von i mean that one
we've got to take responsibility for
that man well i don't know i think joe
needs to take some responsibility
because he's got his [ __ ] stone yeah
and then sent us off to interview
theovonne yeah and blessed theo lovely
man phenomenal comedian by the way
generally one of the best communities
when we saw him live afterwards it was
insane he was insane like so good and it
was sweetheart as well really nice guy
but he turns up a sober dude to two
comedians podcasts that he's never
watched were clearly off their nut yeah
yeah it was weird it was weird thanks
joe
hey kkk do you believe in spring
cleaning yes but only when my wife does
it in russia men who clean are executed
for not being real men which is correct
well for those men who are living in the
21st century manscaped has an incredible
offer for you manscaped are the global
leaders immense below the waist grooming
and have forever changed the grooming
game with their amazing performance
package 4.0
inside this care bundle you'll find the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop provider turner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of boris johnsons treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
sent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and will have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger20 at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code
trigger20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
the stuff that we we are
putting out as a result of this trip is
going to be high quality people are
going to love the interviews it's going
to be so exciting for us to see people
because like you said like it's been
such a leap for us to be interviewing
these people um
who we who we've always wanted to talk
with you know
because and also for me you know there's
a
there's like uh an intellectual
challenge yeah part of it which is like
can i dance the dance with sam harris
yeah and i actually thought we did
exactly that we did you know we we we
held him
we we were with him and whenever he said
things that we thought you know his
logic was faulty like we knew what to
say you know what i mean there's always
that part of it too like you're you're
you're talking to some smart people now
yeah sam harris was one of those people
he had a rich billionaire vibes when he
came in yeah and he just sat down and by
the way what a nice dude what a lovely
lovely lovely man we had some tech
issues and anton was faffing about for
with the trying to work it out and
whatever it was taking a long time and
we were like okay [ __ ] it like look i
don't want to i don't want to waste any
more of your time sam anton let's just
do and he was like no no guys guys i
don't have anything planned for the rest
afternoon so just take your time and
we'll do it right
and he gave us we did an hour 40
interview with him longer than that yeah
so he was supposed to be here
from midday until one and he left at
like 2 30.
you know it was great it was incredible
and he wanted to keep going i wanted to
keep going yeah we all did but we had
you know we had things with places that
we needed to be at dinner dinner exactly
but what what a pleasure what a place to
sit with a mind as brilliant as sam's
and just hear him talk yeah absolutely
that was incredible and you know
bill was fascinating as well because
he's on an interesting journey as a
person yeah you know he talked a lot
about
basically you know becoming a better
person and how that's affecting him and
how other people see him as different
and all that yeah and you know how to
become not only a better person for
yourself
but arguably more importantly better
person for your children
absolutely and of course it was
hilarious yeah absolutely hilarious yeah
you know and there were a few little
digs at both of us in there yeah yeah
yeah there's even when you watch it a
little bit of a dare i say [ __ ]
impersonation to me bill
was there yeah i remember oh right back
to the camera yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think it was a [ __ ] impersonation of all
british people yes exactly a collective
impersonation of all of us
uh but that was fantastic and uh and by
the way there's people who we didn't
interview but like bridgette fetishes
yeah what what a quality human being she
is absolutely brilliant known from the
cut from the comedy seller nom who runs
the comedy seller chris williamson who
you know showed us around austin i love
his channel modern wisdom people should
check it out he's just been on rogan
literally yesterday yeah as we recorded
it so he's crushing it and he really
looked after us yeah i mean seb gawker
was just like amazing yeah um you know
everybody that we got to hang out with
it was just a mensch
as your people would say yeah but uh
we went to like the comedy cellar we saw
kevin hart live live
i mean there were some bits that weren't
great the one bit that was funny oh my
god oh man that was incredible that bit
was incredible tj miller
he's had his critic
but
he was phenomenal look it was
the whole thing was just touched by
magic yes it was
it was
right from the first day
and not there you know
we couldn't have done it without our
like
like i said man when i looked at my
phone yesterday i was just like
i can't believe this is my life yeah you
know
and
um that's why we talked to joe about
gratitude it's like
um you know the feeling of gratitude
that you and i and anton
feel
and and
this is the thing i think people
probably watch the show and think like
we're we're packing millions away in our
bank accounts like we haven't got any
money at all no
right ignore the surroundings
we really don't no we don't we don't
we make enough money to pay ourselves a
reasonable modest salary and to pay our
staff that's what that's all the money
that we have it's not like we we've
built a compound like tim paul or joe
rogan or whatever
but
just being here yeah and doing this it's
like bill bursa just like none of us has
a real job no and our job is this yeah
this is what we do and that's why we're
so happy it's not like we came to la and
bought a [ __ ] mansion no
we are we're delighted
because we get to do this yeah
and we get to do raw yeah
and we get to be free and we get to be
free and we don't have to muzzle
ourselves and we can do the jokes that
we want and we don't have to beg comedy
promoters for opportunities or whatever
we're just doing our thing and there's
an audience out there for that exactly
and it's just like bernard manning yeah
a good man
compared to a lot of comedians
i mean more moral probably far more
moral
but
[Music]
it's not untrue
uh but
that is how that is because of the
people who support us
it's the people who like i said one-off
donations it's the amazing audience that
we've cultivated
this works because of them yeah
and that's why when i go back
a lot of my excitement is going to be
from just going
they're going to lose their minds when
they see the billboard interview
or
they're going to get so [ __ ] pissed
off with sam harris
it's exciting yeah man it's so exciting
that we're gonna give them these amazing
interviews but i'm gonna be honest with
you like
i don't know what other podcast does
that
it's just going to be great and just to
get the feedback and people going
or people just going yeah that was
brilliant i think already had that part
yeah exactly
i mean sam harris is going to get that
yeah
yes he is yes he is
but
you know one of the other things i
learned from joe as well is
how
dispassionately he is he dispassionate
he is about disagreeing with people yeah
when joe rogan says
i don't think that's true you don't feel
attacked no you don't
right like for example you said right at
the end of the conversation that people
who say that boring fighting is is bor
you know certain styles of fighting are
boring and they're not real fans anyone
that's not true yeah and he gave you an
example but you didn't feel like you
were attacked or humiliated even though
you should have been yeah right
for not knowing your [ __ ] exactly
destroyed with facts in life yeah you
know what i mean of course and that
that's one of the other things that i
really hope that we can cultivate with
our show is
like
i think
when we were starting out a lot of
people felt that
they attached and projected their own
political views and ambitious on
ambitions onto us they thought
that we have a particular ideology that
we follow yeah and
we we are the vehicle by which that
ideology will win
right but that's not really true
we want to talk to different people and
so one of the things that means is we've
got to be able to talk to someone like
sam
with whom i disagree very profoundly on
some of the things that he said in that
interview you know yeah and we've got to
be able to talk to him and talk to him
in a respectful way of course in a way
that he feels heard in the way that he
feels um that he was worth his time
coming here that's really important that
that's the only way we progress if it's
just talking points
uh you know i've got this one you've got
that one i don't think we're gonna get
anywhere you know and if we're gonna use
the internet we've talked so much on our
show about the damage
the damage the utter damage to our
society that social media is doing big
tech companies are doing
you know then we have to offer something
that is the antidote to that at least
here
at least in the hour or two hours that
we spend with somebody we've got to
create a space where different
conversations can be had and different
people with different voices can be
heard i've always said my dream week at
trigonometry would be to release nigel
farage on a wednesday
trump on a sunday
no farage on a wednesday corbin on a
sunday jeremy corbyn yeah that's what i
want us to be i want us to be and we are
but continue to be and grow as being the
center yeah where we interview everybody
and you come here
and you know what you're gonna get
is a fair hearing and you're gonna get a
chance for you to say what you think and
why you think it and you'll be asked the
questions that normal people normal
people will want to hear an answer to
not some journalist [ __ ] yeah you
know some people would say this and
no yeah what what a normal person me or
you like we're normal this is the thing
that makes the show work yeah we're just
normal people yeah we have normal
questions we try to think about things
in a common sense way we're not we're
not you know political philosophers or
whatever yeah we're just trying to ask
the questions that most people would
like to know and sometimes those
questions are more intellectual because
you you know that there are people out
there who want the the mind nourishment
of an intellectual conversation and
sometimes it's more practical it's about
you know day-to-day politics and
sometimes it's entertaining or sometimes
it's about a really
you know
i think high-stakes issue yeah like the
grooming gangs or like the trans
conversation right now where children
are being mutilated yeah and
i feel a lot of vindication now that
you're seeing the maya four starter case
the allison bailey case the tab is still
getting shutting down
for you know being one of the first
people in our space
um
all the feminists are going to get
pissed off now because they've been
talking about it for years but in terms
of
podcasters who come from our background
comedy
we talked on rogan about how scary it
was to talk to posey yeah
but i feel we were intellectually honest
in that moment we challenged her as best
we could to try and save our careers
yeah we couldn't
and we were like well she's telling you
know what she's saying makes sense to me
i'm not gonna pretend it's not true yeah
and we carried on and we continued to
explore that issue and continue to
highlight that issue because you and i
genuinely care about those children who
are in finding themselves in that
position and that's why it's so
important
that we go back
yeah and it's why it's so important that
we
we will come to america we will spend
time in america but at its heart it will
always be a british show hosted by two
british guys
it's just we because we've got are you
getting to replace me mate yeah exactly
but we can't pretend to be anything else
the show works because we're honest yeah
that's true rogan our appearance on
rogan went for four and a half hours
because if you were pretending to be
someone else no one's that good an actor
that you can improvise for four and a
half hours yeah
the mask is gonna slip i don't care how
talented how smart
you just can't yeah and that's what you
get with us this is who we are so
for me
this has been a joy
i love america
but we've always got to continue to look
at the world through a british lens
it's [ __ ]
there we go
all right mate well uh before we go i i
think
i you know in the spirit of gratitude
yeah um we've said gratitude you know
our gratitude to our supporters and i um
i really really appreciate them so much
yeah you know i thought you're gonna go
for the jesus thing there just want to
thank jesus thank jesus yeah well
actually i wanted to thank you because
we've been through a lot together
yeah
here we have
you know
yeah
this was planned guys no we really have
here we have man
well you know and
because
it's easy
when you're watching the other side that
you think that
because when i it goes to [ __ ] and we've
had our differences
but i always know that you've got my
back
and you know
the thing in life is there's very few
people who've actually got your back
there's a lot of people who say and
there's a lot of people who act like it
but the moment that the [ __ ] hits the
fan
that's when you know you've got i'm a
friend
yeah so i really appreciate you man
i appreciate you too man will you marry
me
no guys
guys
it's okay
[ __ ] work done
well done boys semester thank you so
much thank you anton thank you
you made it we all made it